my name is Susie Q I'm Miki mom my name
is Venus Lux and I'm a sex worker and
I'm a sex worker and I'm a sex worker
I'm a sex worker but I don't have sex
every single day I'm a sex worker but
I'm not worthless I'm a sex worker but
I'm not incapable of having a
relationship I'm a sex worker but I can
also educate people about sex but I'm
lucky enough not to be estranged from my
family my mom and dad are awesome and
supportive and amazing but I am a
businesswoman too I'm a sex worker but
I'm not gonna have sex with everybody
that I meet but I am not ashamed I love
my job but I get tested twice a month
but I've not ever in a situation where
consent isn't present but this was not
my only option just because I may tell
you that at a cocktail party doesn't
mean you can ask me for sex advice
that's weird I'm a sex worker but I
don't do drugs but that doesn't mean I'm
glamorous and sexy all the time my go-to
outfits are usually yoga pants sweat
shirts and my glasses I'm also human
I do have emotions I don't have sex
every single minute I'm a sex worker and
I'm a podcaster my podcast the [ __ ]
cast has been showcasing the stories art
and voices of American sex workers for
almost three years now I'm a sex worker
and I think sexual education isn't
important I'm also an educator and a
voice of the transgender community and
I'm a nerd may the odds be ever in your
favor
I'm a sex worker and I'm not offended by
the word [ __ ] and I'm against human
trafficking I'm a sex worker and I do
not have SDI's I also enjoy doing
nonprofit work I'm a sex worker and I'm
also an author I'm a sex worker and I'm
proud of what I do for a living I'm a
sex worker but that's not all I am I'm
much more you just got to get to know me
I'm a really complex normal kind of
awesome human just like you